Kaleigh we're gonna take care of you
know get you on bachelor live if you'll
accept after failing to get through busy
phone lines last week bachelor Ben
Higgins invited Kaley Cuoco to be on
bachelor live on Monday night the
actress accepted his invitation joining
us via Skype Kaley Cuoco well we have
you here and I have been so go ask
whatever you want is all of you I've
never been speechless I don't know what
to say The Big Bang Theory star joined
by her younger sister Brianna and a few
girlfriends including former
Bachelorette Ali Fedotowsky did manage
to ask one very important question
you know what I've chosen I think we're
losing our connection some sort of solar
flares
we got the say goodbye Chris Harrison
was joined in studio by guest Chris
soules and Kris Jenner the momager
answered a fan question about which of
her kids
if single would most likely go on the
dating show to find love it would be who
could I talk into it I would I would say
like one of the younger ones but Kenda
wouldn't go for it I don't know I could
talk them into it though